standing by with all the latest it gets
closer and closer it does yeah it does
automatic recount Lara Statewide if it's
less than point five percent okay you
got that got it that's where we begin
this year okay because look where we are
we're at point nine percent between
David McCormick and Dr Oz and Kathy
Barnett you heard her speech a moment
ago dropped off well over uh into third
place a short time ago so you ask
yourself now Laura where are the
remaining votes where do you find them
throughout the Keystone State and the 67
counties on the board here
um just just a reminder this is
Pittsburgh over here in the West
Philadelphia down here in the Southeast
a Harrisburg in the center part of the
state if you look at the outstanding
vote that remains now you go southeast
of Pittsburgh Westmoreland County that
is by the way the place where Donald
Trump went and had the rally with Dr Oz
about a week and a half ago Pittsburgh
here this is Westmoreland County right
now decent County you know out of 67
counties Statewide Laura it ranks number
10 in terms of population they have
about 60 percent of the vote reporting
which means 40 percent of the vote is
still outstanding right I mean pretty
simple math right even this late hour we
can do that that's in Westmoreland now I
want to take you across the state and
show you what we're getting here in the
Southeast this Philadelphia down here uh
the green area I showed this a short
time ago Bucks County Strong population
4 out of 67 a moment ago it was
reporting that
um only 18 percent of the vote was in uh
if that's the case and they've got a
ways to go let me pop around here a
moment here Montgomery County 3 of 67
they were reporting less than half of
the vote in at 40 percent so still a
ways to go there as well down here in
Delaware County five of 67. these are
you know a lot of folks live down here
in Southeastern PA they were at 27
percent of the votes so a lot there in
Southeastern Pennsylvania uh still
outstanding that may make up the
difference again between McCormick and
Oz and determine and really the the
outcome the ultimate outcome here uh pop
up here this is Northampton County
um and you you see Oz leading McCormick
in this Pacific County but there too you
have just about half of the half of the
vote is in so there's more ballots to be
counted out there come down here to
Lancaster uh Pennsylvania here yes got
it so they're around the same area as
Northampton along the Susquehanna River
here Lancaster you got in the Farmland
here Amish territories Amish country as
well in southern Pennsylvania right
along the southern border there
Lancaster is reporting about 54 of the
votes in so there is still so I get in
summary Laura what I would tell you as
of 10 41 PM East Coast time uh in
Pennsylvania you're really waiting on
this part of the state here uh to clock
in and we'll see how much this changes
and since we've been talking here uh
We've reduced the count to 0.8 percent
this number says 95 percent of the vote
in that that is the s estimated vote in
I began the beginning of the night based
on what we believe through the
Associated Press and others could be the
projected vote that number can change
you can go higher it can go lower
depending on when the votes are tallied
when they come in if you get a good
turnout this number could as we saw in
Virginia last fall that number start
remember went Higher and Higher and then
started to drop down a little bit that's
because of turnout and that that could
be the case in Pennsylvania tonight uh
but we'll just have to wait and see here
but as as we stand right now Laura
you're at point eight percent remember I
said 0.5 I think I did I think I told
you you did so bill um I'm just seeing
that right now McCormick is up eight in
Allegheny County
which is a significant
that's a significant difference an
Allegheny for him right now is it eight
and seven eight percent yeah you're
right yeah good math yeah that's right
well that's awesome that's also key but
we're still missing key areas of
Philadelphia and Bill you've been around
this game so many times why is it that
Philadelphia seems to always
if you're talking about the collar
counters around Philadelphia they report
pretty well uh the city of Philadelphia
which is also the town of Philadelphia
right here okay the reason we haven't
talked about that a lot is because if
you go and read this a little bit here
uh Laura you're you're not talking about
a ton of votes If This Were a Democratic
Primary in the in the uh between
um let's say fetterman okay look I mean
you see the difference fetterman today
picked up almost 35 000 votes on his own
Conor lamb came in third in Philadelphia
he got 25
000 okay on the Republican tally Oz is
at 7 500 McCormick's at five thousand
you so you see Philadelphia the city of
Philadelphia is a it's about
85-15 Democrats to Republicans so
there's just a slight distinction there
but your Point's well taken about the
collar counties here bucks and
Montgomery and Delaware and it looks
like in Bucks County
the numbers come in for
mccormicker also I guess decent correct
in Bucks County yes
McCormick's got of the vote that's
tallied he has 3 000 raw votes Dr Oz has
2300 and the difference is seven
percentage points
got that
okay officially Lara back to point nine
percent wow bills this is it's so great
to be on the air with you at the
billboard it's awesome thank you so much
Phil we'll check back with you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else